in this way the organism appears to the
observing consciousness as a relation of
two fixed moments in the form of
immediate being of an antithesis whose
two sides on the one hand appear to be
given to it an observation and on the
other hand as regards their content
Express the antithesis of the organic
notion of end in actuality but because
the notion is such as a face there in
the antithesis is expressed in an
obscure and superficial way in which
thought is sunk to the level of picture
thinking thus we see the notion taken to
mean roughly the inner and actuality the
outer and their relation produces the
law that the outer is the expression of
the inner
in paragraph 262 Hagel is going to lead
us to what we've got here is presented a
new law the outer is the expression of
the inner a Hagel is not actually
endorsing this law wholesale as we're
going to see as we go through the this
paragraph and the paragraphs yet to come
but he is putting that out there you
might say well why is why is he doing
that well he is examining some of the
key ideas of his own time they have to
do with the observation of a matron what
we're looking at here is the observation
not just of nature and such but organic
nature and as we're going to see as we
go through the next couple paragraphs
not just all organic nature but
primarily animal organic nature and
ultimately you know human organic nature
in the next section I don't often bring
up other commentators on handle because
I want to stick very closely with the
text but this is actually a passage
where I think it's useful in this
respect to this passage of the ones yet
to come to remind yourself of something
that John had believed the great French
early translator of Hegel had to say
about this this section of observing
reason in particular and when here's
what he said in a nutshell and I'm
roughly paraphrasing it may seem overly
scrupulous or as if we're spending too
much time on stuff that doesn't really
matter to look closely at Hagel's text
here because what we're dealing with is
you know Hagel's own critical reaction
to a science that none of us except
anymore as you know an adequate science
of nature and he points out that look
we're not really interested in hegel's
critique of you know shelling or or you
know other people at that time what
we're interested in is the core ideas
that these show up you might say really
large in any other way of observing
organic nature that we can we can find
still around today and I leave that to
you the viewer to think about so let's
let's turn to hegel's text now he talks
about observing consciousness and what
we have in my ear is of course observing
reason observing organic nature in terms
of the organism we've just spent the
last several paragraphs unfolding what
it is to be an organism it involves you
having a sort of and in itself the
notion of N and you notice that what
we've got here is what's you know being
translated by Miller is an antithesis a
gay in the honse right and we've got a
split that takes place here so he says
the organism appears to the observing
consciousness is a relation not just
breaking down into two things but a
relation so there's a there's a hole
there of two fixed moments in the form
of immediate being and he says this is
an antithesis whose sides are the one he
had appear to be given to it in
observation so observing reason is
supposedly observing both of these in
observing the organism and we're going
to see that again played out in the next
few paragraphs so he says this is the
antithesis as respect to their content
of the organic notion of
and in actuality now what we're going to
see very quickly is these two get
replaced by some other important
determinations but let's see what we
have so he says that since the notion is
effaced the antithesis has expressed an
obscure a superficial way in which
thought has sunk to the level of
pictured thinking so we have lost sight
of the notion the grid of the concept
and instead we not only having a
survivor image here but we're engaged
with images on on both sides so
observing consciousness is not grasping
it in a conceptual way full way but in
terms of the pictures that it's able to
make for itself yeah and we just saw
just you know a few paragraphs before
that this opposition is something that
observed in consciousness tailors to its
own capacities so he goes only says we
see the notion taken to mean roughly
something else beginner right and
actuality comes to be taken to be the
and the relation between them which is
the organism itself ends up becoming
something other than the organism and
ends up becoming the law well the lot
this law the honor is the expression of
the inner so now we get something
formulated that says okay this is how
reason can actually understand what
happens in an organism in terms of law
once again the outer is really which is
what we can observe more easily the
expression
the inner now we have to explore what
does that mean and what implications of
that hat and is it even true at all
when we consider more closely this inner
with its opposite and their relation we
find that in the first place the signs
of the law no longer have the same
import as in the case of previous laws
in which they appear to self subsistent
things each is a particular body nor in
the second place do we find that the
universal is supposed to have its
existence elsewhere outside of the two
sides on the contrary the organic being
and its absolute undivided nas's made
the foundation as the content of inner
and outer and is the same for both
consequently the antithesis is still
only a purely formal one whose real
sides have the same in itself for their
essence but at the same time since inner
and outer or opposite realities and each
is a distinct being for observation they
each seem to have observation to have a
peculiar content of their own however
this peculiar content since it is the
same substance organic unity can in fact
only be a different form of that
substance of that unity and this is
implied by the observing consciousness
when it says that the outer is merely
the expression of the inner we have seen
in the notion of em the same
determinations of the relation that is
the indifferent independence of the
different sides and their unity in that
independence a unity in which they
vanish
so now in paragraph 263 we get to see
handle beginning to explore what would
this mean to have this this law remember
what a lot supposed to do is to provide
us with the essence the universal the
intelligibility of what it is that it is
is the budget and remember two of the
laws are not supposed to have any sort
of you might say areas of in
applicability or exceptions so the law
says that the the outer is the
expression the Ouse talk of the inner
and with respect to what this is the law
that is going to pertain to organic
being two organisms to those things that
are indeed ends in themselves that are
self-producing and refreezing now Hagel
is going to call some of this into
question not the whole thing the part of
it here and so let's look at what he has
to say says when we consider more
closely this inner with its opposite the
outer and the relation the relation of
expression of externalization we might
say we find that in the first place the
signs of the law no longer have the same
import as in the case of previous laws
but it was he in there well in the case
of previous laws what was supposed to be
happening is there's a lot of individual
cases or instances or matters to use the
you know term that you used earlier in
this section montanari then the law that
applies to so you know think about the
laws you have to do with electricity it
has to do with static electricity has to
do with lightning which actually turns
out to be static electricity in a
certain way although Hagel didn't know
that at the time you know also with what
we might say the electricity involved in
alternating current and D secret all
these empirical things that we can
observe they can be brought into one
heading of a law a general conception
that ass
do with with electricity as a foreskin
in nature right now that would be
multiple instances here we're going to
talk about multiple instances because
you don't get the outer and the inner
separated from each other except say
perhaps as Hagel said in terms of
picture thinking for Stella we're going
to find that well in a textbook or in a
Wikipedia article or in a you know
computer-generated game in which you
could distinguish between the two things
you're separating things that are truly
separate from each other and Hagel
points out that they they both have the
same foundation this organic being which
is going to function as the universal of
the law is looking for here so he says
we don't find the universal supposed to
have its existence elsewhere outside of
the two sides with with the previous
understandings of law you've got
particulars and then you've got the
universal provided by the law here
somehow the law is something that needs
to be intrinsic to the organic being
reason is supposed to be discovering
this law because it's already actually
there in the organic being that because
reason is simply pasting it or
projecting it until the world after it
comes up with it and it's study or it's
armchair on its own right so he goes and
he says on the contrary this organic
being as absolute undivided is made the
foundation as the content of inner and
outer and is the same for both so the
organic being is is providing a
foundation it's providing what actually
is there and where we've got these two
aspects of at the inner and the outer so
observing reason wants to go after as
Hagel says the con
tenth of both of these and understand
that content interestingly enough inhalt
right so you certain way more inner than
outer but it wants the content of those
idiot it's not really able to have a
grasp on them as he says a peculiar
content of their own why not because
each one of them reveals that what's
really going on here inner and outer are
both as Hagel's going to say forms he's
not saying get out there snap shapes its
form which is you know the counter you
might say the the counter position or
the correlative to content me am so he
goes oh he says this peculiar content
since it's the same substance or organic
unity can in fact only be a different
form of that substance of that unity and
this is implied by the observing
consciousness when it says that the
outer is merely the expression of unit
that grasped as such but implied the
outer is merely in we might put it this
way another form what is over here in a
different form but they're both forms of
the same organic being so now we're
seeing the meaning of this law gettin
played out a bit more and at the same
time it doesn't appear to be saying what
we originally thought and this law seems
to be in his Hagel's put it pointing out
to us rather different than other was in
in important ways so he says we've seen
in this notion of n the same
determination of the relation that is
the indifferent independence of the two
different sizes and their unity in this
independence the unity in which they
vanished
uses a term there that we've seen so
many times how are we going to hold a
question to keep in mind how are we
going to hold inner and outer in view as
we're making sense of them
we have now to see what shape the being
of inner and outer each has the interest
such must have an outer being and a
shape just as much as the outer as such
for it is an object or is itself posited
in the form of being and as present for
observation
here in paragraph 265 we get one of
those ever arising Hegelian paradoxical
statements which arrest you and make you
say well what is it happening here it's
a very short paragraph but in hegel is
saying something that a certain sense
should throws for a loop it actually
makes perfect sense when you unpack it
but when you first hear it like I said
it's a paradox it strikes you as they
can't possibly be right and what this
shows us is Heinkel working as a
phenomenon just as in certain respects
being more willing to follow a reason
where I will go you know reason is
consciousness then reason itself is and
Hagel begin as this by saying you know
well what shade what Gestalt shawls you
know forms of consciousness shapes of
consciousness does each of these tick
does the inner and the outer take and
now eagles not going to worry so much
about the outer as such we can observe
the outer right that's the directly
empirical we might say but now he's
going to say something at least at
today's paradoxical about the inner says
the inner which is the inner right must
have an outer being and shape now he
doesn't say something like the outer he
says just as much as the outer so this
should raise some puzzles well in what
sense is it actually inner then there's
there's a a you might say a subjective
intensity or a death to the inner that
the outer the / Flocka the superficial
doesn't actually possess now why does
Hagel say that this is the case he
doesn't say here's my metaphysics I just
happen to think
that inner has outer as well and you
know it's better to have both at the
same time right he's not saying that
what he's saying in the rest after the
ellipsis that I've got there is the
following he says it is an object or is
itself posited in the form of being and
as present for or observation right its
consciousness as we're observing it
ourselves were the observer observing
observation that is producing what we
might call the outer inner of the litter
itself so let's blow on this just a
little bit because this is this is a
important doctrine at something that
commentators have called attention to
and I think it will be useful since
we're now working with these terms inner
and outer if something was purely
interior purely inner how would we
possibly know what it is how would we
possibly even grasp its presence or its
absence let alone its determinate pneus
do we have you know special senses that
can just sort of peer into things the
way you know intuition on Chavan was
supposed to remember Hagel doesn't
doesn't go for that other philosophers
of his own time we're doing things like
that sometimes in terms of grasping the
absolute is such sometimes in terms of
you know some having something like a
moral sense that leads us a bit of
strain I heard especially so I don't
like a too caught up yeah but that's an
example of that now Hagel is you know
people talk about him as being an
idealist and you know being captivated
by his own ideas Hagel is so empirical
that he thinks that we have to really
observe what's going on he's like
William James in that respect more
empirical than the empiricists
themselves so if observation is that
you're going to be able to make a sense
of this contrast between hitter and
other the inner has to be present in
some sort of outer that is not merely an
expression of according to the law but
which is actually this this inner so we
get to outers so that's something to
dwell on a little bit we're going to see
this come up in other respects later on
but that's probably enough about that
that point right now
the organic substance as in ER is the
simple unitary soul the pure notion of
end or the universal which in its
partition equally remains a universal
fluidity and therefore appears in its
being is the action or movement of the
vanishing actuality whereas the outer
opposed to that existent inner subsist
in the quiescent being of the organism
the law as the relation of that inner to
this outer thus expresses its content
once by setting forth universal moments
or simple essentiality and again by
setting forth the actualized
essentiality or shape those first simple
organic properties to call them such our
sensibility irritability and
reproduction these properties at least
the first two seem indeed to refer not
to the organism in general this is but
only to the animal organism as a matter
of fact the vegetable organism expresses
only the simple notion of the organism
which does not develop its moments
consequently in regard to those moments
so far as observation has to take
account of them we must confine
ourselves to the organism which exhibits
them in there developed existence
paragraph 265 is going to continue
Hagel's examination of this law that the
outer is the expression of the inner and
it's going to bring us in the end to
talking in terms of these three
essentiality he calls them or properties
or or you might say functions of the
organism which definitely in the next
paragraphs to come he is going to
examine and you might ask at this point
well why those particular three here is
where we're seeing Hagel responding to
the attempts at natural science of his
own time which were largely figuring
things in terms of these these three
functions as nuns that these have been
entirely abandoned as being you know
essential to the organisms but there's
are conceptualized in different ways and
we don't need to get too hung up on that
at this point or even under the pier is
to come so Hagel is going to say the
organic substance can be understood in
terms of the inner and the outer it
begins the paragraph by talking about
the inner he says that the organic
substance as the inner and remember we
just had this this previous paragraph
where he's talking about the inner
itself the outer out of the inner now
he's talking in terms of the simple
unitary soul a conception that many
people in our own time have completely
rejected but you know if you want to
understand what Hagen's going you have
to sort of put that put that aside for a
moment and bracket your your disbelief
in the existence of the soul this is a
common idea then there is some sort of
you know unitary thing doesn't
necessarily have to be a floaty ghosty
kind of thing there's something that is
unitary that is simple in a certain
respect then it binds the entire
you know organic being together
Aristotle called that a solo tu ke and
aerosol thought was the form of the body
here we're not even talking about you
now sold on a theological status but
more in the sense you know we might call
the unity of the living being he also
says that it's the you know we've talked
about this the pure notion end or the
universal so no real problem there we
already understand you know what the
pure notion of n it is because we've
talked about that paragraph after
paragraph insofar as it's the utter he
said is that it's the quiescent which is
a nice translation of Rodia restful you
don't at rest being static we might say
static so the inner is dynamic the
author is as outer static all right it's
got us determinations and it is what it
is so now here's where it gets more
interesting though he says the law is
the relation of the inner to the outer
right what law the air the honor is the
expression of the inner right so we've
got this relation of expression there
the law he says is a relation between
universal moments or simple essentiality
to which then become actualized
essentiality or we're asking about this
earlier shape gestalt gustav can't be
something purely inner or it's not going
to be gestalt it has to externalize
itself this is a key idea of a galleon
dialectics that it's nicely have things
that are inner and inwardness and you
know interior already and all that but
unless it externalizes itself unless it
appears in some way it really doesn't
matter it's kind of a pragmatic criteria
let's go let's go on he says the law
expresses its content once by setting
forth Universal moments or simple
essentiality and again by setting forth
the actualized essentially
or shape those first simple organic
properties to call them such are what
sensibility sensibility death
irritability and reproduction three key
things that characterize living
organisms Hagel's going to say a little
bit later more animals than planting
things plants basically just reproduce
themselves but being able to sense an
external world to relate oneself one's
consciousness to externality and then to
be able to respond to us your ability
doesn't just been getting mad or you
know being touchy it means being able to
respond in coherent ways to a changing
environment so he says these properties
at least the first two seemed indeed not
to refer to the organism in general but
only to the animal organism right okay
so plants now we know that planets
actually do in certain respects sense
their environment um you know they can
tell where water is for example they
respond the heat they turn towards the
Sun if they're they're trying to catch
that sunlight so we might even say that
they have some of that aspect of
irritability you know especially when we
get to things like you know venus
flytraps catching flies well that sort
of stuff as well but it goes on he says
in regard to those moments so far as
observation has to take account of them
we must confine ourselves for the
organism which exhibits that in there
developed existence so now we're not
going to look so much at organisms per
se at plants for example we're going to
think about animal organisms or we know
we might think of other things that that
have these characteristics that are
central to living things